professor Oliver them share the Nobel
Committee could you describe to us what
is circadian rhythm so circadian it
writes Trumble actin so circuits around
and day is babe and this is the daily
rhythm we have to anticipate and adapt
to the dramatically different conditions
during day and night that arise from the
rotation of the earth the three
laureates
what problem have been solved for a long
time that there are diurnal or circadian
rhythms but how it worked wasn't unknown
at all and it was debated for a long
time whether it was a response to
external signals or something endogenous
and they before they started their work
it was understood that it was endogenous
and it was even understood that single
genes could influence the circadian
rhythm but nothing was known about the
mechanism and there were different
hypotheses but they found out the
mechanism that controls the machinery of
the clock so he turned to the discovery
what were the key findings and who did
what so first of all they studied they
used the fruit fly as a model system and
before their work there has been a
classic experiment by Benson and Konopka
they had used a fruit fly to ask him can
you identify mutants that arise due to
mutations in single genes so that was
sort of a basis before our laureate
started their work and they took
advantage of that because the the gene
wasn't known there were mutant strains
known who had long or short or no rhythm
at all that were known to map to the
same locus so the laureates use these
tries and went on to isolate the gene
and to determine what gene it was but
that didn't prove the mechanism either
so what they then did was experiments to
understand the function of the system by
this gene and then several others that
they did in sequential experiments
why is circadian rhythm important so we
need the circadian clock to anticipate
the daily changes not only adapt but
anticipate so it's so there are
dramatically different conditions during
day and night and we need to be very
active in the day and other processes
need to take place during night and
evolutionary it's been a very great
advantage to take to use the only
critical lights hours where minutes of
the day for instance if you're if you're
hunting you need to be active or if
you're hunted you need to run and hide
so you need to be prepared and take
advantage of be that one step before the
the environment that's why we need it
it's this kind of clock is it this is it
all ourselves so we know that most of
ourselves have this clock and we also we
knew before these discoveries that there
is a central clock in the brain that
controls the rhythm and then later it
was found that it we also have them in
other parts of our body but it's the
it's actually the mechanism that the
Rorie's have elusively
it's an auto regulatory self sustained
inhibitory feedback this what they found
that order for in an accessible way
would it be it's a metaphor one could
use the clock is a metaphor easy but for
the mechanism it's it's a little bit
difficult but it's an oscillator so you
build up a substance and then when the
substance is there it turns off it
sounds production and then it can start
over again so it becomes an oscillation
so a negative feedback of its own
synthesis that's the best I can do like
an hourglass when the lower part is full
of sand and it's time to turn around
doesn't really shut up its own synthesis
so it's hard to find something similar
actually so an oscillator and the
mechanism for the oscillator by shutting
off its own synthesis in a regulated way
so it becomes self sustained autonomous
or medicine there's a huge field of
chronobiology chrono medicine it's
really exploding it's a fascinating area
but in humans most beta on specific
diseases are so far correlations so we
don't really have the firm evidence to
postulate the circadian clock so does
this or that when it comes to disease
there are some examples there are sleep
phase disorders where you actually have
mutations in the core some of the core
clock genes and then you have a shorter
or a longer face and that causes
problems with sleep that's a solid thing
but in humans apart from that there are
lots of correlations there's more known
of course in animal models where you can
disrupt the clock and then see effects
another example is jet lag of course but
that's not really a disease but that
indicates that when we're misaligned so
that our inner clock does not match or
is misaligned to the environment at work
then we really feel bad but then of
course there's a lot of interest in
trying to understand if our lifestyle
today with social jetlag has
implications for disease and that's very
actively studied but so far mainly
correlations sometimes you feel kind of
bad
wintertime whenever in Sweden and the
darkness how much with one coat how one
shark oh well that's a big question
well I what I can say regarding that is
that there's so many things that we need
to understand and also the the core
machinery it's a lot more complex but
the concept is the same but we now know
that there are more factors regulating
and stabilizing there are interconnected
loops and there are mechanisms for
entrainment so you adjust the clock
mechanisms for synchronizing clocks
throughout the body and output
mechanisms so other genes are sort of
hitchhiking on the system and controlled
by the same mechanism and all of this is
really really dynamic and we're learning
so much so although the all of these
implication questions what it means were
help that really remains to be to me
nailed down now and they have provided
tools for that by understanding this
mechanisms we now have a way forward to
address these issues laureates three
Americans Wallace he was born in 1945
he worked very closely together with
microtia
they have been working together since
the mid mid 70s and they are about the
same age my rush is one year younger
Paul is retired but my rosebush is very
active still and Michael Young is also
an American he worked independently they
have also had some collaborations but
he's at Rockefeller University he's also
spent a very long career at Rockefeller
and he's still very active finally has
Nobel Committee you've been able to
reach you know the knowledge yes sir so
our secretary-general professor thomas
Berman he has reached rose fashion hall
but he's not been able to reach to
Michael Young yet question what do you
think is the best about this price and
it's such a fundamental prize it's a
detailed molecular mechanism but it
explains how we are as after to the
planets I think it's a very fundamental
thing and it's important for so many
things and it's opened so many questions
and enable so many questions